o Hello whitwell your eyes wide open CD
Chico Buarque Roberto Grade games your
answers you know who you are but first
you know and helps you help yourself how
can we get across and funny Way people
and stem cells will have a license this
song for me choreography  and Clear
Message In
Hello all Safari to the end to see the
answer is my good you give her moved that
I have a
the system graces anime One Piece of
Heaven fuchsia lipstick a big brother Soul
Surf Ron Jon Surf with kesly only that the
walbruni boat  Hello all Safari to use
pearls too I can take Break and
visit so it has a caipirinha flavor it's
not so close
movie your blood in which period is mine
took you understand so it's
[Music]
[Applause]
I am I want
oi Rafael Hey
there
[Music]
Hey Hey
HeyHey